[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
i hope you all had a wonderful holiday
and i just wanted to let you all know
that i've got tons and tons of videos
planned for 2021
for today's video i'm going to be
discussing the order of the phoenix
and the hunt for horcruxes the order of
the phoenix is of course a secret
society
that was originally founded by
dumbledore in the year 1970
the purpose of the organization was to
oppose lord voldemort
and his followers and it was the same
organization that valiantly fought
against voldemort and his followers
for 11 years before voldemort's first
defeat
after the first war the order disbanded
however
when voldemort returned in 1995 we
picked up where they left off
the organization is filled with a
multitude of powerful witches and
wizards
each boasting their own unique magical
abilities
but one thing that could potentially
appear strange is
why didn't they help harry to locate
horcruxes
surely an organization full of powerful
auras and professors
could have helped harry ron and hermione
couldn't they
a horcrux is an object in which a dark
witch or wizard has imbued part of their
soul
the ultimate purpose of creating horcrux
is to achieve immortality
however the truly sinister component of
creating horcrux is that in order to
produce one
you must murder someone voldemort began
creating his horcruxes in the year 1943
starting with the diary of tom riddle
which was produced as a result of the
murder of moaning myrtle
after that he went on to make many more
and the tricky part about horcruxes
is that there can be almost anything
making them exceptionally hard to locate
as long as the horcruxes existed
voldemort would continue to stay alive
which meant that locating and destroying
them was essential
so again if destroying voldemort's
horcruxes was the only way to defeat him
why on earth was the task left to three
students why didn't they use the
manpower of the order
the answer to this is actually pretty
simple the reason that the order didn't
help
is that they simply didn't know about
horcruxes when dumbledore told harry
about the existence of horcruxes
originally
it was between him and harry only
dumbledore also instructed harry not to
tell anyone else
with the exception of ron and hermione
and never told anyone else
himself but there's also a little bit
more to it than that
the following conversation between harry
and mcgonagall at the end of the half
blood prince
reinforces this after glancing once at
this portrait professor mcgonagall made
an odd movement as though stealing
herself
then rounded the desk to look at harry
her face taught and lined
harry she said i would like to know what
you and professor dumbledore were doing
this evening when you left the school
i can't tell you that professor said
harry he'd expected the question
and had his answer ready it had been
here in this very room
that dumbledore had told him that he was
able to convide the contents of their
lessons
to nobody but harry and hermione harry
it might be important
said professor mcgonagall it is said
harry very
but he didn't want me to tell anyone
professor mcgonagall glared at him
potter harry registered the renewed use
of his surname
in the light of professor demodo's death
i think you must see that the situation
has changed somewhat
i don't think so said harry shrugging
professor dumbledore never told me to
stop following his orders
if he died so what's the deal why didn't
dumbledore want anyone else to know
about the horcruxes
why did he tell harry alone and leave
everyone else in the dark
surely he should have seen value in the
order of knowing shouldn't he
here's the thing dumbledore felt that
every extra person who knew about
horcruxes was a possible weakness
if word spread about horcruxes somehow
and voldemort himself found out
then he would have likely put additional
preventative measures in place
to protect them ensuring his immortality
not only that
but dumbledore didn't want to put
additional lives in danger
although harry didn't find that part out
until the end
dumbledore always knew that harry would
need to die in order for voldemort to be
defeated
so he figured that it was safe for harry
to go after horcruxes because he was
always destined to die
anyway dumbledore's betrayal was almost
nothing of course there had been a
bigger plan
harry had simply been too foolish to see
it he realized that now
he had never questioned his own
assumption that dumbledore wanted him
alive
now he saw that his lifespan had always
been determined by how long it took him
to eliminate all the horcruxes
dumbledore had passed the job of
destroying them to him and obediently
he'd continue to ship away at the bonds
tying not only voldemort
but himself to life how neat how elegant
not to waste any more lives but to give
the dangerous tasks to the boy
who had already been marked for
slaughter and whose death would not be a
calamity but another blow against
voldemort
the only reason that dumbledore allowed
harry to tell ron and hermione was that
he figured that harry would probably
tell them anyway
harry also asked he turned to go then
another question occurred to him
and he turned back again sir am i
allowed to tell ron and hermione
everything you've told me dumbledore
considered him for a moment
then said yes i think mr weasley and
miss granger
have proved themselves trustworthy but
harry i'm going to ask you to ask them
not to repeat any of this to anyone else
it would not be a good idea if word got
around how much i know
or suspect about lord voldemort's
secrets no sir i'll make sure it's just
ron and hermione
good night harry followed dumbledore's
orders to a tee and even when he was
questioned by lupin at grimmell place
harry never revealed what his mission
was he only acknowledged that he
had a mission lupin and the order were
naturally curious about what harry was
up to
and wanted to help but harry wouldn't
give it up lupin hesitated
i'll understand if you can't confirm
this harry but the order is under the
impression that dumbledore left you a
mission
he did harry replied and ron and
hermione are in on it and they're coming
with me
can you confide in me what the mission
is harry looked into the prematurely
lined face
framed in thick but graying hair and
wished that he could return a different
answer
i can't us i'm sorry if dumbledore
didn't tell you
i don't think i can i thought you'd say
that said lupin looking disappointed
but i might still be of some use to you
you know what i am and what i can do
i could come with you to provide
protection there would be no need to
tell me exactly what you're up to
harry hesitated it was a very tempting
offer though
how they would be able to keep their
mission secret from lupin if he were
there with them all the time
he could not imagine the reason for
harry's hesitation of accepting lupine's
offer was that he felt that there would
be no way
that he could complete his mission in
their presence without them finding out
in some capacity
in order for harry to successfully
pursue his mission
no one could know and he simply couldn't
take that risk no matter how much he
would have liked their help
and company in the end the only person
harry sort of told about horcruxes was
neville
and that was right towards the end of
the second wizarding war on his way to
voldemort
harry realizing he would die felt that
there should always be three living
people that knew about the horcruxes
when he bumped into neville just before
seeing voldemort he instructed neville
to kill voldemort's snake
nagini explaining that nagini needed to
die
in order for voldemort to die harry
never looked suddenly scared
harry you're not thinking of handing
yourself over no
harry lied easily course not this is
something else
but i might be out of sight for a while
you know voldemort's snake neville
he's got a huge snake calls it nagini
i've heard
yeah what about it it's got to be killed
ron and hermione know that but just in
case they
the awfulness of that possibility
smothered him for a moment made it
impossible to keep talking
but he pulled himself together again
this was crucial he must be like
dumbledore keep a cool head
make sure there were backups others to
carry on dumbledore had died knowing
that three people still knew about the
horcruxes
now neville would take harry's place
there would still be three
in the secret just in case they're busy
and you get the chance killed the snake
killed the snake harry repeated so i
hope that answers the question
if you enjoyed the video please hit the
like button and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams
and forget to live